speaking of comedians what's the deal
with jim carrey saying he was sickened
by the statement
he's right he's right he's right we were
all sickened and these guys gave him a
standing ovation everything he said was
accurate yeah he's like i was sickened i
was sickened by the standing ovation i
felt like hollywood is just a spy is
just spineless and mass i feel like oh
this is really clear indication of what
that were not the cool club anymore jim
carrey said when asked
i didn't understand that last night but
i agree with it i didn't know how that
connected but he's right
and then he said i would have announced
this morning that i will be suing will
for 200 million because that video is
going to be there forever it's going to
be ubiquitous that install is going to
last a very long time this is a great oh
that's facts right there that's a great
point like
this is going to be memes it's going to
be gift everything he ever does in his
life is going to come back to this
you know the oscars already announced
that when chris rock dies that's his in
memoriam
cause they're going to show
no not that he's just getting slapped
you see him getting slapped but that's
how he's gonna live for the rest of his
life
even when he dies you're gonna see that
clip yeah yeah it's like it's like oj
like i don't know oj is a football
player
oh you yeah he doesn't like i'm not a
huge football fan but like he just
doesn't exist to me as a fall player
he's existed to me as like i used to
play sports i killed a girl
and i'm like this is not obviously on
par but like is chris rock is his legacy
he's going to be overshadowed i feel the
same way about o.j and i'm older than
you right like
he's actually good at football that i'm
like yeah i think he was nice he was
incredible yeah then he crossed over he
was like naked gun
and he was funny
yeah yeah i just know him as like as a
person he's a guy that killed someone
but i'm like this is not the same person
black man who got off
yeah that's what we meant to say thank
you very much for clarifying yeah but
like it's like cosby it's not the same
thing but it's like with him is it gonna
be
oh yeah like you were this amazing actor
comedian but also you got slapped by
will smith yes also that yes unless he
can flip it in this new tour
now he can't flip it and talk [ __ ] about
will but he's got to be able to make
jokes about it
to the point where he can like address
it in a way where we go i guess that was
kind of funny and your reaction was
reasonable because right now the
reaction looks soft not saying he should
go and [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] at him but
there he should have been like told what
to do and then immediately capitulate he
shouldn't have just sat there and also
like [ __ ] continued to read the
teleprompter
like
he should have stopped the [ __ ] thing
and said get him out of there
he just slapped me i'm being
professional because i don't want to
ruin this award for everybody else
that's here and i don't want to ruin
this night but he's not allowed to slap
me and just keep staying here for the
rest of the show and you at least say
that off stage but it's also so tough to
tell somebody how you would react when
that happens because not only did you
get slapped there's no way you thought
you were actually going to go
and then by the time you process what
happens he's back in his chair yelling
and you're just like what yeah i have so
much empathy for you just slap what the
[ __ ] yeah like you said this has
happened to you yeah you got slapped and
you're like what there's no clap for you
you just cannot believe it did you have
jane joke i really think he meant it
when he was like that was a gi jane joke
dude if he slipped it though
that was just so funny i think he put
his face into it because he's gonna be a
faith flat a fake slap he's doing this
right like he thinks he's just gonna
play tap him and then go back sit down
and he really slaps him but the way he
handled it really opened up
the criticism that you can give to
hollywood which is
something good so maybe on his tour it's
like he doesn't come for will but he
comes he says okay [ __ ] the movie
industry goes back to like having the
control that co that a comedian can have
he would never he he wouldn't he's too
beholden he could he wants it too bad he
could and you know i'll have some
empathy when you're in your late 50s or
whatever he's in you're probably like
like russell said something that stuck
with me when he came on flagrant he was
like i don't have the heart for that
anymore when he talked about doing the
n-word on def jam but yeah i think when
to give chris rock some empathy i think
he's like dude my kids are grown his
kids are shifty's age
like 50 something how's he 60 i think
he's 57 is what i read somewhere bro 50s
definitely 50s right yeah and like mid
50s i've been doing comedy for 30 years
i'm kind of done with the fearless part
kinda yeah like i'm
and we also don't know like [ __ ]
chris rock's personal constitution and
how he like handles those things but
bare minimum the show failed him like
they failed absolutely they failed to
keep him secure and uh and they honored
the guy yeah
a tweet someone put out was like uh in
order to calm will smith down they gave
him a statue of jada that's fair
that's really funny but they literally
gave him an award then he had to like
celebrate dude can you imagine being
asked to present an award getting
slapped
and then the guy who slapped you gets a
bigger reward than the one you were
presenting it's crazy and the fact they
just let it happen is it's mind-boggling
yeah
mind-boggling all right guys we're gonna
take a break for a second this is
something that i'm very excited to share
with you guys right now they're
sponsoring the podcast but this is fire
uh why don't you wipe all your personal
information off the internet imagine
there was a company that could do that
for you imagine all your personal [ __ ]
you don't even realize your personal
[ __ ] is up there it's up there your
phone number your address your email
your family's addresses your family's
address the social security number
aliases relative ip information [ __ ]
shopping habits it's all across the
internet you don't realize how many
places it's in trust me it is it is
scary how much is out there and you can
wipe that [ __ ] from the internet if you
use incogni okay
incognity is absolutely brilliant i'm
telling you they have the ability to go
across the interwebs and wipe all that
personal information that should not be
on these dark sites should not be on
these light sites either should not be
on any [ __ ] site your personal
information is yours and yours alone and
you should be able to control it so you
can request your personal data removed
okay without dealing with the other
objections that often happen okay you
might not realize it but there are
companies that are selling your data you
know you ever subscribe to like a
newsletter or something like that and
all of a sudden you're getting thousands
of other emails yeah they sold your data
we're gonna wipe that [ __ ] with
incognito off of the internet so they
can't keep doing that that's right they
don't have the right to do that maybe
they do i'm not sure but you know it's a
pain in the [ __ ] ass and they
shouldn't be able to so people can look
you up they don't know you find your
parents addresses your relative address
your phone number you where it's it's
crazy absolutely cut all that out cut
that [ __ ] out and i'll tell you this
right now the first 100 people to use
the code schultz schulz at the link
below are going to get 20 off of
incognito protect your privacy today go
to incogni i n c o g n i dot com schultz
use the code schultz to take your
personal data off of the market okay
it's not theirs it's yours you keep it
yours with incognito let's get back to
the show well that's what zoe kravitz
was saying and then she got rinsed i
didn't think she could get any hotter
somehow she did
defending the comics god bless this
woman yeah she goes here's a picture of
my dress at the award show where
apparently we assault people on stage
now god bless her and then they came for
her yeah took the comments off because
the dress was mid what was the dress
she she posted a second one too the
second one's for you care about the
dress nah that dress is fire yeah oh
yeah come on get out of here this one is
crazy together
that's the og one
now that one sucks that's what i'm
saying yeah that one's made but this
one's firing that one is straight
up i didn't see that one that's nice but
yeah she just doubled down
and people came for her they're like
someone said your wife yeah what were
they saying someone said something like
so you uh don't understand will
defending his wife or something like
that and she just said nope all caps the
uh
what i saw them coming for her
for was uh that like they're insinuating
that she was like a pedophile or
something because she said that jaden
was so mature and when he turns 18 when
he was 14 at the time when he turns 18
that she's going to date him or
something he said something like yeah i
was hard i had to remind myself he's not
18 when we were yeah but she's being
silly like this is not got to be silly
anymore in hollywood yeah you're not
yeah i guess let's keep the same energy
yep i guess that's keeping jade also
[ __ ] jaden's friend
who she helped recover from a drug
addict so if you're gonna get upset at
someone making comments about being
attracted to a kid i know one is legal
and one is not but you [ __ ] your son's
friend that's like a whole porno
category
how this is the one where we're going
after i have i see no fault with
anything zoe did that's a whole porno
cabinet yeah
what else are they getting on zoe for
that but fa had a list of things i
almost feel like it's a uh like cultural
like counter reaction like you see it
all the time where like someone will
have like a point that's
not really nuanced and then people
reject it completely in the not nuanced
way also so i feel like conservatives
are like ripping on
on like will smith and blah blah and
then on twitter people are like oh we're
just going to double down the other way
will smith was justified like every day
online yeah okay
but like people are just like doubling
down without really thinking because
people are [ __ ] on will so hard
people that they don't like this thing
yeah yeah they're like i can't agree
with ben shapiro that i must i can't
agree with candace owens like yeah oh
that's what you think it is
i think there's a party part of like the
twitter sphere there's like a fight that
already exists yeah and then everything
gets put into the columns that of that
existing fight so where does the chris
rock uh will smith be fit into this
already existing political fight yeah oh
ben spears going this way well i got to
push back against him because i'm part
of this column and that's how i think no
matter what yeah i also think a lot of
these people just have to take i guess
take a certain side or like have an
opinion that's um they're kind of like
comics but not funny yeah where it's
like let me have an opinion that's
whatever the algorithm also just
incentivizes you for having a wild
opinion yeah yeah having a unique
opinion and there's a lot of um unique
or
columned opinion like i think the
algorithm will incentivize you for
having that right wing opinion or the
left-wing opinion but the unique one i
don't know if there's that much room
with it because i think people are just
going there to confirm their beliefs
yeah that's true right they're just like
hey i agree with everything ben shapiro
says so ben how do we feel about
will smith you might chris you might
retweet um like a unique opinion but the
one that sticks and gets the most
comments and engagement is the one that
fits into the side
so i see what you're saying but i do
think he's probably writing that it's
like oh but this side makes me feel
triggered to use the word so that's the
one i'm gonna really feel passionate
about this unique one is cool but this
one that i agree with passionately
that's the one i'm into right but yeah i
think that's part of the reason why it's
getting kicked up so much on twitter
there's a lot of uh i was really happy
to see a black woman get defended and
that's fair but
are you not tired of seeing black dudes
get assaulted yeah like that's that's
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
they completely left that out huh yeah
it's a black man getting humiliated
getting assaulted and nobody does
anything to the guy who assaulted him
who for whatever it's worth is lighter
but also is richer and more powerful and
that guy gets away with it and the black
dude gets humiliated emasculated yeah
gets uh condemned for disproportionately
for what he did gets punished
disproportionately for what he did and
nobody's talking about that you were
that happy to see a black woman get
defended that none of that stuff matters
to you
that's a little crazy i think
yeah if will had just screamed
as a comic i'd be like go to interrupt
the show
but that's it yeah that's what jim
carrey said he was like you can scream
if you want to voice disapproval go on
twitter or whatever but like you're
going to slap someone for words like
words should never justify like physical
violence whatever whatever
yeah i agree with that
but i agree kareem had a pretty
thoughtful
response where he said something like
buy
if will wanted to scream you can
disagree or not but that's fine but to
slap him it's actually sexist and that
you're saying uh anything that jada
could do
i need to protect this woman from words
because she's so weak and frail yeah she
can't do it herself yeah yeah she can't
even handle words yeah i think it's just
will searching for his identity and
now he believes that he's the i protect
my family at all costs guy and uh you
think he's still in character no i don't
think will knows who he is
and i think that he wrapped himself
around his success and then when the
success started to fizzle a little bit
he lost his
identity and now he's searching for it
and i think he's searching for it
furiously and he just can't find it
because he doesn't actually know who he
is if we can agree with he lost his
identity don't you think it's possible
he wrapped his identity up in his most
recent role that also is getting him all
these accolades which is richard
williams protective father i don't buy
that
i don't buy it i i i see that and i
think that's what he the narrative he
tried to push but i don't i don't buy
that i i don't
i think it's possible to get like
influence from that and be like okay
maybe i'm this guy whatever for sure i
think it's possible yeah but i think
that the the crux of it is he just
doesn't know who he is outside of being
that i'm the number one movie he said
something to jaden one of their red
table things which is like i had no
self-worth my self-worth is wrapped up
in making her feel good or all these
accolades which is a lot to what you're
saying i imagine
and i have no proof to back this up so
i'm just talking [ __ ] at this point but
i imagine
jada's approval
is very hard for will to get
and that keeps him in this relationship
and it's almost competitive like he is
fighting to get approval from this woman
who won't really give it to him there's
this whole tupac thing where like that
was the one that was supposed to be and
as silly as it is for us that this
superstar will smith could be with this
you know kind of
lower tier actress and really care
about her validation when he could be
with any girl on the planet we believe
in his mind he's like i like this girl
she don't like me i have to do anything
to make her happy oh an open
relationship be more evolved try out all
these different religions and all this
other goofy [ __ ] anything to get her
approval
and
that's his fault and a little bit of her
to blame if you want about i believe in
personal accountability but like maybe a
little bit of hurt for maybe
manipulating and taking advantage of
that situation yeah but that's what i
surmise just be honest and be like hey i
don't like it when people [ __ ] my wife
this is really hard for me
and
no i'm being serious like
if he just came out he was like
guys i've been lying to you guys
and
i don't like it when people [ __ ] my wife
that would be the most relatable thing
that he could possibly say yeah and it's
it's it frustrates me i've tried really
hard to be okay with people [ __ ] the
dog [ __ ] out of my wife extremely
relatable yeah everyone's at home like
you're saved yeah
i do feel the same way that's a bummer
yeah yeah
you know it's one of my non-negotiables
yeah my life shouldn't get [ __ ] by
other people yeah yeah
and you know about it yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah there's no way that we can control
second non-negotiable yeah like [ __ ]
don't tell me no there's no way we can
control if that happens we can only you
know
because it's if we don't know we just
don't know right but
there's no way in hell someone's gonna
be [ __ ] my wife and they're gonna
still be my wife that's just divorce
right there
so you won't be my wife you're not gonna
[ __ ] my wife and i know about it yeah
you can [ __ ] the woman i love
you
and the person i've dedicated my life to
my wife is the only thing i can control
i can remove that wife thing
and i think that's kind of what's sad
about this
it is sad and it's a good when this
thing blows up hard
and this relationship is done within
three years i'm curious to know these
people who are so on board with this and
think it's okay are they gonna step back
at all and be like oh yeah that was
actually it's britney spears that was
insane what was happening it's britney
spears free brittany free britney she's
free shaking her hips back and forth and
doing up camera and uh yeah losing her
[ __ ] i watch every single one
everyone every single one i watch right
one dance move back and forth yeah
and
and then we make one of those videos yes
we have to immediately fire you walk in
just yeah and then walk off have to yeah
but yeah it's like we supported it now
we see that she probably should have
somebody kind of looking after her you
know her boyfriend's walking around with
[ __ ] quarter million dollar watches
and [ __ ] and
second after because she's not doing
anything wrong i'm like that's true who
cares like yeah she might be look crazy
to me on social media but like a lot of
people are crazy i think time will tell
with her but again you're allowed to be
crazy there's nothing illegal about that
yeah as long as you're not hurting
people yeah and she's not hurting anyone
yeah do your thing but um i think it
will be similar to that where it's just
like i think the problem with this
situation right now is that after this
happens she can't break up with her
yeah i i don't think they split up i
think if you got through the august
alcina [ __ ] like this is going to be
light work because everything's going to
go up his book sales are going to go up
anything like he does books nah i even i
even got his book after because now
i just want to check it out i know he
has a book now i didn't even know yet
yeah
chris rock sales is going up i think
it's going to be good for everybody
everybody's going to tune in to red
table talk like chris might financially
are going to want to chris rock might
financially win but you're never going
to look at him the same you're just not
no he's got to address it and then that
if he addresses it how do we look at him
will be dependent on how he addresses it
and if he has a really good reason for
why he did what he did and he's so
[ __ ] smart he'll be able to cook one
up
i think that he could get around it but
he has to address it what up people you
just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.comflagrant2
all right peace
you